Antonio sabato jr. a actor and underwear
model he was a featured primetime
speaker at the Republican National
Convention and he went on to tell ABC
News during an interview that President
Obama is a Muslim he did an interview
after his just amazing rousing speech
and we will play a little bit of that
for you right now first of all I don't
believe that the guy is a Christian I
don't believe he follows the guy that I
love and the Jesus that I love I think
he has an agenda from the beginning I
think he's so then the interviewer is
seizing on that choosing to go back to
it tell us a little more underwear model
Antonio sabato jr. what about President
Obama tells you that he is not a
Christian religion seems to be very
important to you why is it that you
don't believe that President Obama is
Christians as the man who regularly
attends church services family no he
does not actually he does not attend
church yes he has never talked about
Jesus Christ once I you know I have met
a lot of Christians I know Christians
III I am one I don't believe he is and I
think why why don't you believe he is I
just see it for what it is I believe
that he's on the other side I think the
side or the middle east right he's with
the bad guys he's with them he's not
with us he's not with this country he
doesn't support Obama isn't a Christian
name he hasn't ever talked about Jesus
Christ Antonio sabato jr. former
underwear model has met Christians and
it's in his heart that Obama is just
flat out with the bad guys in the Middle
East not with any of the Christians in
the Middle East not with any of the Jews
in the Middle East but specifically with
the bad Muslims in the Middle East this
guy's a genius how does he know so much
stuff Luis it's incredible apparently
you learn a lot on the set of an
underwear shoot but I think this guy
would be great friends with Scott Brown
yeah oh and Scott Baio who has been at
the Republican convention this
convention rachel has been way funnier
than the feud between Taylor Swift and
the Kardashians in my view yeah I can
but I also think that what he's saying
is kind of not that outlandish in terms
of what other Republicans have said
because there was a poll a few years ago
and I think it was about over a third of
Republicans said that they believed that
he was actually he is a Muslim and it
was interesting because 65% of those who
who thought that he was a Muslim were
uncomfortable with that fact so maybe
what he's saying isn't kind of isn't so
much out so far outside of the lines of
what other Republicans have said but
still yeah my initial reaction was wait
a second you've got a sort of birther
type at least going not not specific not
literally a birth there but a birther
type who says I know that the truth is
Obama's a Muslim how are you going to
allow someone like that to speak at the
convention and then as Rachel mentioned
actually about a third of Republicans
pretty recently shared that view and
Donald Trump Louis was one of the most
vocal birthers over the last few years
so actually although my reaction is you
would want to keep someone like former
underwear model Antonio sabato jr. as
far away from the stage as possible he
actually reflects the views of one out
of three people presumably in that room
if it's a if it's a sort of average
representation of Republicans yes of
Republican voters no doubt and it's it's
really it's mainstream its mainstream in
that party you would think that if it's
so mainstream the Republicans should
have made that part of their platform
yeah Obama is Muslim the platform was
completely off the deep end anyway at
least put in that they should and maybe
maybe even something about the birth
certificate why not so rounding out the
convention with some celebrities Antonio
sabato jr. actor Scott Baio who was by
the way completely off his rocker I mean
seemed to I don't know if he had a small
stroke while while he was talking doing
interviews or what happened to him but
totally incoherent I guess Angelina
Jolie's dad ted nugent and kirk cameron
were not available
for the particular at the time that they
would have made speeches insane disaster
and we will talk to you more about it
after the break
Warby Parker is offering a free five day
home Tryon to give you the opportunity
to check out their glasses I personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of
these free at home try ons of five pairs
of glasses you can get your free home
try on and support the david pakman show
at Warby Parker trial comm slash TDP s I
don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses while the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home Tryon I was
able to pick five pairs that I liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I liked the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane
Warby Parker glasses start at $95 that's
what mine cost and for every pair of
glasses sold Warby Parker distributes a
pair of glasses to someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like check out the at home trial and
support our show by going to Warby
Parker comm slash TDP s it costs nothing